when you died I felt like there was a
hole I missed something but it wasn't
you
it was the idea of what you could become
but Dad please know that while I am
grateful and highly aware of all that
you've given this family I still don't
miss you
when you died I felt like there was a
hole I missed something but it wasn't
you
it was the idea of what you could become
I miss being able to Hope and wish that
one day would turn a corner and see the
world from my perspective I missed the
idea that one day you might help me
fight for the things that matter I
missed my fantasy of you
because when you died it solidified the
fact that she'll never be what you could
have been but only what you are and what
you are is a racist misogynistic
xenophobic trump-loving sister straight
white man that is all you will ever be
to me and Dad before you tell me to
respect the dead please remember that
you disrespected and disregarded the
lives and death as an entire communities
of people with your ideology you told me
to Never back down so I won't you know
for a fact that even against you I'm not
afraid to share my peace you are
everything I Aspire not to be and I
refuse to stand up here and sing the
Praises of a man who was the Paradigm of
white supremacy so I'll take your racist
mindset I'll take your money and I'll
take your advice and I swear to God I
will make this world a better place not
at all because of you but an exact
opposition to you
think
whenever it's funny because feedback I
don't think feedback is is is is an
accident feedback always comes when
there's an awkward moment it's like when
your microphone is gang banging
okay so there you guys have it no she's
a mixed girl is that what I understand
yes okay and she didn't like a race of
that yes
he died and that's the speech he gave
yeah I saw everybody feeling this was
sad some people felt like where are we
at in the state of the country where
people are talking about their parents
that way a lot of people had like
negative takes about it I understand
she said some stuff that was interesting
she said
um I'm not mourning your death I'm
mourning the death of the person that
you never became
clearly
um however we feel we don't know the
dead we don't know her so we don't know
what the dynamic is he could have been a
really bad person you could have been a
really good person and she's unfairly
fairly characterizing so depending on
which one is true I probably feel very
differently about it right if the
argument is that he's a bad person
because he supports Trump and he
supports this and he's probably like not
you know for the black lives matter
movement then a lot of people are gonna
be like does it sound like a terrible
person to me and he supported you
financially and he was present a lot of
people if I look at it like does it
sound like the word staff but we don't
know the intricacies of that
relationship so it's hard to really
judge he had enough influence in her to
teach her to be like a go-getter to
speak her mind to tell the truth or
whatever she is but he was also a bad
dad it sounds like they just had
difference politically speaking that's
what I'm surmising yeah where she's like
either pro-trans and he's completely
anti yeah and that was a source of
conflict she's very politically inclined
with how strong so how do I feel watch
this first part her morning
could we never be get to become I think
oftentimes children who lose their
parents early on it's like especially if
you have the greatest relationship like
you're not just mourning the death of
your parent you're mourning the fact
that y'all never had a relationship that
you didn't really have a childhood with
a parent person or you didn't have
there's a lot of mourning that happens
from different phases so in that regards
I understand what she's saying
completely like sometimes your parent
isn't really a parent yet they just
birthed you and they haven't gotten like
mature enough or stable enough to be
able to be that pair so you're more than
the fact that you never even got them to
see them be a parent in your life and so
there's a lot there that probably hurts
and so in that regards like it's
interesting and I think it's worth
unpacking on the other hand
our parents come from where they come
from
as an immigrant I could never think like
she did and if most immigrants did we
don't hate our parents because if we're
being honest vast majority of immigrant
parents hold some form of like racist or
anti-lgbtq or anti this group this
ethnicity view that's just a fact I
could never imagine having her mindset
and having any relationship with my mom
me and my mom have very strong
difference in opinion when it comes to
politics she votes probably drastically
different than me probably because she
votes and I don't but that's not the
point that's what I was about to say
yeah a lot of you guys like yo Apple you
I'm like [ __ ] I ain't a bot [ __ ] is you
talking about I'm out the Matrix okay
let me not talk about that that's
irresponsible you want to I believe okay
we'll make that another video okay I
just want to trigger some of you guys
and I got you gotcha [ __ ] let's stay on
this topic
I don't think you could and I think one
thing that people need to learn to do a
lot better is to learn to have
relationships with family members
despite feeling different politically
maybe that means you guys don't talk
about abortion at the dinner table I
know I know it's a big talking point
move on and if they're saying a bunch of
dumb [ __ ] about LGBT just let them have
it maybe you'll have a small discussion
but once it gets contentious walk past
it because I think between family
members it's okay to have diametrically
opposing political views and still
maintain that cohesive because in my
opinion maintaining that bond is more
important than being able to share the
same political values that's me maybe
I'll feel differently but I know that
most families wouldn't be able to exist
if they necessitated that the other
party shares the same kind of voting
threats so what I think is sad about
this more than anything
is that she sat there and she said all
this stuff about her father and
obviously the man's passed
um but it meant that even when he was
living they prioritized their politics
over their relationship at least she did
and that's what's sad to me
so yeah okay actually so someone else is
saying she's reading the eulogy she
wrote for a deceased father in an
academic environment what do you think
art
whenever you do art at some point it is
a form of wanting attention you want to
bring attention to something attention
is not necessarily necessarily or
inherently bad right wanting attention
or wanting to put attention on something
or a specific subject is not necessarily
A Bad Thing and yes it is just to me
it's a thing you want attention for
certain things and you want to bring
attention to certain things so yeah and
it's it's it in the context of Art
if she knew that it would gone viral
maybe I would understand where you're
coming from but if it's someone else
that filmed that [ __ ] and put it and
posted it you know I mean so I'm like
hey what it's whatever to me she's just
performing art that's what it is to be a
bit extra and I see this a bit like
um slam poetry
there's a bit of that in there with that
that's what they want they they put they
put a context where oh I performed this
my dad died and this and that and that's
where I took my uh my my inspiration
from so I can understand where that's
from you know I mean so
so what's the difference between her
saying yo my white father died and he
was like that so I think this person
there and I'm forming peace and I wrote
for eulogy and in into Art Academy
environment whatever what's different
between that and a gang banger and
making a song about the people that he
dropped in
firing from a traumatic event or talking
about the hood that's something that
happened does he want attention well I
think basically people are like she's
glad or she seems like yo [ __ ] [ __ ] her
dad kind of thing and I think it's an
okay sentiment you have the right to be
pissed off at people yeah you have the
right to be pissed off even that family
but it's your dad if I understand that
you Hey listen all men are created equal
but not all dance
repeat
that's a bar
the pig 63
. some parents yo it's like
no no do your thing yeah so to me
what's the difference between this and
that you know I mean she took it and she
did something out of it yeah but she
wanted attention yeah but some people
that do that and take report stories
from the hood and put it out there uh or
not only taking uh advantage of the
people that died and the families that
are are mourning and suffering not only
doing that but they're also taking
profit of like a actual Prophet people
are doing profit off people that are
dead so we
I don't really see the difference
between one and the other like we permit
one but we we're going to bash the
others so if that's how she feels we
just feel that way because it's her dad
and she suppose you're supposed to love
your family unconditionally and no
matter what happens no there's some
people
there's some people that depending of
what happened and how they wronged you
you're gonna be like no that person's
death to me or that I don't don't agree
with that person or that yeah I think
it's okay
to dislike even your own family I think
it can happen depending on what happened
what happened and what's your sentiment
is she right that's not for me to judge
I don't care at that age
the politics means so much like you take
it like as your identity and everything
that happens to her just being a mixed
kid
I think that it's already hard just to
be a big be a mixed kids you have to you
have to go through who am I yep am I
this one my dad am I both am I how does
it like how do I fit in then you kind of
have to choose a camp nah you know it's
hard for people and I've haven't seen
that
they're either one or the other not a
lot of people Embrace Embrace both you
know I mean in any kind of way in any
kind of way so
she chose to side with black people so
if I'm with him you over there so and
there's all that black lives matter it's
very emotional [ __ ] you're trying to
figure out who you are who you are as a
person who you are as a woman who you
are as a mixed kid who you are are
politically and at that age everything
that goes against your grand if even if
it's like your parents
and even without that at that age you go
against your parents because you gotta
assert yourself and you gotta you know
live through your [ __ ] so there's all
that kind of dynamics that you have to
take in consideration right maybe
eventually she's gonna realize I
remember when I was at that age I was
pissed off about my by my parents I was
pissed off and if something would have
happened or my parents would have died
and I would be her age I would have
probably the same thing the same thing
happened to me and I would have probably
said the same thing yeah but when you
grow up you go older and then you get to
understand your parents you get to
understand where they're coming from and
why they're saying what they're saying
if you become you make some money and
you become more conservative
that's not funny
that's not that's not funny that's not
that's not funny that's facts
but you become you start you start to
pay taxes when you were a kid you're
like everything needs to be free this
needs to be free and then you can you
get to comprehend that oh [ __ ] ain't
nothing in this [ __ ] free ain't nothing
it doesn't work like that it does not it
cannot because at the end of the day
when you understand how taxes work it's
gonna be my nothing is free you
understand so you want all these things
people are going to end up paying for
you you get to you get to get older you
get to mature you get to understand
where your parents were coming from you
also get to act like the parents you
didn't want to act like
yeah and then you're like that's a weird
[ __ ] feeling and then you understand
where they're kind of going from you're
not going to be 100 like your parents
but you understand what it's from at the
end of the day it's DNA you know what I
mean so
I understand why she's saying what she's
saying at that age because I was that
age and I was pissed off at both my
parents understand when I move out of my
house when I move up man not so young
older than that when I move out my house
I'm actually when I move my out my
parents house
and they made that clear that it was not
my house so when I moved out
I didn't talk to them for like two years
after that I was there at Social
Gatherings and [ __ ] but a phone call
that was not me
that was not me if they would call I
would say
less you have to have that separation
from your parents from that household
from from knowing what and then you
realize okay you learn a bit a little
bit a lot about life you mature and then
you reflect maybe she's gonna reflect on
it in the future and she's gonna regret
what she did it's a possibility
or maybe not we don't know but I
understand
and yeah all that I said all right let
us know what you guys think in the
comments